vous favorable à la vaccination
obligatoire pour tous oui c'est vrai on
vous a déjà posé la question mais si on
voulait repose c'est d'abord pour cette
évolution puisque on est avec justement
des spécialistes des résultats et des
chiffres et des sondages en novembre
dernier seuls 38% des français étaient
pour
aujourd'hui c'est une majorité et s'est
passé à 58 %
toujours selon aux docks ça on vous pose
la question aussi après avoir entendu
littéralement ce coeur des luttes
politiques en faveur
justement de l'obligation vaccinale
beaucoup scientifique conseille la
vaccination obligatoire au moins dans
certaines professions et pour les
publics à risque
devant cette nouvelle escalade du risque
ne pensez vous pas qu'il va falloir
envisager des décisions en ce sens avant
l'automne uni avec le co vide on y est
donc oui je crois
sans stigmatiser 100 m d'oukases sans
pointer au mur les soignants je crois
qu'il faut rendre la vaccination des
soignants obligatoires moi j'ai toujours
pensé que ça finirait par la décision
collective de rendre la vaccination
obligatoire pour toute la population la
vaccination bigard comme comme les onze
vaccination on donne aux bébés à la
naissance et à pâte a bloqué là on peut
faire des échéances que c'est ça la
priorité nationale aujourd'hui c'est de
stopper la pandémie est donc une
vaccination billets parallèles c'est la
vaccination qui est notre véritable arme
contre le virus je pense qu'à un moment
il ya une une priorité nationale une
priorité sociale une priorité de
cohésion protégeons les autres et donc
nous faisons en sorte que nous soyons
d'accident jean louis bourlanges dans le
figaro ce matin le professeur d'éthique
médicale emmanuel hirsch écrite
l'exécutif évoque l'obligation vaccinale
pour notamment pour les soignants faute
je cite d'avoir su donner à comprendre
la signification démocratique de cet
engagement et cette responsabilité
est ce que cette obligation si elle
était votée si elle a été actée puisque
justement il est question que les
députés à se prononcer dessus d'ici la
fin du mois
c'est pas le signe d'un échec c'est
facile de dire qu'on a on ne donne pas
aux gens le sentiment d'engagement
moyens démocratiques c'est extrêmement
difficile actuellement
on le voit bien tous les partis ont du
mal à mobiliser
et à mobiliser les électeurs pour des
élections les gens ont effectivement un
comportement individualiste moi je suis
très clair sur ce point mais je crois
qu'il faut simplement prendre ses
responsabilités on le le vaccin est
absolument une arme efficace si on veut
lutter contre la pandémie c'est la seule
c'est là cela ne peut il n'aura pas
d'autres donc soit on fait ça va que ça
soit on retourne tout ou tard à des
confinement et donc je crois et c'est
absolument sans risque donc il ya
vraiment aucune raison que les
responsables politiques le gouvernement
les parlementaires ne prennent pas leurs
responsabilités
même si effectivement ça suscitera des
réactions fortes dans une partie
minoritaire mais active pour des raisons
plus ou moins bonnes parfois très
mauvaise parfois compréhensible de la
part d'une partie de nos de nos de nos
concitoyens gouverner c'est choisir
disait pierre mendès-france et là il
faut faire ce choix et c'est vraiment
pour une fois je trouve que c'est un
choix facile pour un homme politique ou
une femme politique parce que il ya
vraiment y'a rien qui s'oppose à ce
choix sinon la crainte de déplaire
si on ne peut pas s'ils sont ne peut pas
faire passer l'intérêt général avant ça
c'est très ennuyeux
donc je pense qu'il faut prendre la
mesure une mesure assez globale de 2
peut-être l'échelonner un peu dans le
temps donner aux gens un ou deux mois
pour réaliser cette cette vaccination
mais je pense que les partis politiques
doivent prendre leurs responsabilités et
cesser de finasser avec ce qui est ce
qui est vraiment de l'intérêt même pas
général de l'intérêt de tous c'est de
l'intérêt de tous
alors si on n'est pas capable de
proposer un point de vue de proposer une
décision qui est de l'intérêt de tous ce
qu'est ce qu'on va faire quand ce sera
plus compliqué alors qu'est ce qu'on
fait alors vos questions si vous êtes
vacciné oui
double dose je suis vaccinée dès que
j'ai pu dès que j'ai pu légalement être
vaccinés je me suis précipitée et je
dois dire que je n'en suis que que celle
ci chez beaucoup plus heureux beaucoup
plus trop au goût puis ce sera beaucoup
plus tranquille et j'invite tout le
monde à faire la même chose que moi
c'est en tout cas le mieux s'il vous dis
bravo jean louis guillaume suis pas vous
demander votre point de vue sur la
vaccination mais juste une observation
enfin si vous voulez vous le donnez vous
on a on a on a on a l'impression que là
aussi quand même des petites images
traditionnelles on se tait les libéraux
les centristes sont pour la contrainte
et olivier babeau dans une tribune très
très forte très charpenté ce matin dans
le figaro explique justement pourquoi il
est favorable à une obligation vaccinale
olivier babeau donc président directeur
d'un institut sapiens et une partie de
la gauche radicale et de la droite dure
eux sont pour la liberté dans cette
affaire la liberté utilise les mots
eux-mêmes comme toujours à son sont
piégés si on oppose deux mots
obligations au mot liberté est
finalement on a cette opposition c'est
des mots qui sont utilisés dans des
partisans les inversions les arguments
pour plaider la vaccination j'ai pas les
reprendre son job lisa elle les a
énumérés avec la passion et
et conviction les y ont souscrit
pleinement
après comme les mots sont piégés le mot
obligations fait toujours peur et il
suffit de même que peut-être même parmi
ceux qui réclament l'obligation le jour
elle serait décidée réagir et peut-être
négativement mois mais après tout j'ai
envie de dire que gouverner c'est
choisir j'aurais pu encore gouverner
c'est décider et décide et parfois
contre contre une opinion majoritaire et
l' oncle ans l'opinion n'est pas n'est
pas majoritaire alors si on veut malgré
tout tout concilier cercle éviter
l'effet contre-productif
les effets positifs posés sous prétexte
qu'on oblige
eh ben je le refuse et où je vais me
rebeller où justement il y aurait moyen
plus simple je ne sais pas mais en tout
cas que qui arriverait même effet c'est
sans rendre la vaccination en tant que
tel obligatoire c'est de conditionner le
plus grand nom d'activités possibles à
la vaccination
c'est déjà le cas aujourd'hui pour aller
on en parlait antenne par les uns même
chose en plus huppé que oui oui plus
écrites non parce que c'est plus c'est
plus le pass sanitaire en ce moment
c'est que là parce que le bateau xena
vol à moi je serai peut-être pour un
pass and allies terreur généralisée
c'est pas plus hypocrite c'est juste
après ma center ou pas ça maintient la
liberté quand chacun aux gens vous
faites ce que vous voulez mais à ce
moment là mais assumer les conséquences
vous ne voulez pas être vaccinés tant
pis pour vous mais ne me demandez pas
d'aller au cinéma ce qui se passe
actuellement dans l'armée cercle pas de
possibilité de partir dans les dents les
bases sur les bateaux ou dans les
sous-marins ou bien en opérations
extérieures s'il n'y a pas de vaccin
mais la wii vous rendez compte que ça
serait dans la vie sociale en termes de
contraintes bureaucratiques ce que ça
signifie pour entrer dans les cinémas
pour entrer dans les restaurants pour
entrer à l'opéra pour vous rendez dans
les moyens navals moyen de transport
présent c'est une affaire c'est
simplement c'est effectivement il ya un
signe de de prudence voire de cuisine la
limiter non il faut être clair écouter
on a envoyé des on a fait des choses
horribles dans le passé on a envoyé des
générations de jeunes gens se faire tuer
en algérie
les gens à accepter tout cela ils ont eu
tort sans doute parce que la politique a
conduit à des résultats terrible en 1940
les gens se sont mobilisés on leur a
imposé des choses extraordinaires dans
l'intérêt général
en 1914 on a sauvé la france comme ça
c'est 140 on a pas sauvés on a perdu
mais en 1914 on a imposé aux populations
là c'est rien à voir elle vous demande
pour dans l'intérêt collectif
on demande à quelqu'un aux gens de faire
un geste
inoffensif utile alors qu'il n'y a pas
de solution alternative et que le bingo
général si on gagne on a l'immunité
collective
on peut vivre tous ensemble heureux
c'est quand même extraordinaire que il y
est même un débat est ce que oui pour
l'asim pas scandale il ya vraiment ici
basé sur ds que est-ce que je vais
peut-être vous allez encore jean louis
hess qui est ce qu'il ya pas une mesure
qui rencontreraient plus de consensus et
la fermeture des frontières par exemple
vis-à-vis du verrière delta a été une
chose dont il a semblé qui a semblé
tabou depuis le début de la crise c'est
toujours les mêmes choses fermeture des
frontières c'est extrêmement compliqué
parce qu'ils les raisons pour lesquelles
on passe les frontières c'est une
obligation vaccinale sont parait
effectivement les anglais pourraient
éviter de faire wembley dans les
conditions où ils le font ça c'est quand
même dément les russes font des choses
absolument extravagantes également mais
toute manière ça passera mais le vaccin
et vaccins obligatoires européen
ça permet de résoudre le problème que
vous posez au moindre coup dur aux
critiques il faut quand même voir que la
liberté des gens c'est de ces de vaquer
sans être obligé de 2,2 d'affiché
constamment 2 me de ne montrer patte
blanche dont il faut et on doit laisser
les gens circulaient au maximum on a une
voix royale contre le
virus et toutes les solutions
alternatives sont des chemins vicinaux
qui en plus dans la plupart des cas
débouche sur des impasses
il faut quand même était il faut 10 et
c'est moi je trouve que je crois au
principe de précaution à condition de le
penser comme le disait gérald bronner de
le penser bien c'est à dire de m en
parallèle ce que ce qu'on risque avec la
décision est ce qu'on risque à ne pas la
prendre
ben là le principe de précaution il est
100 sans aucune équivoque on ne risque
rien en vaccinaux et on risque beaucoup
de choses on vaccine pas guillaume
je sais que vous avez un édito à écrire
donc cedar question jugez donc il se
nourrit je retiens deux secondes jean
louis bourlanges pour pouvoir vaquer
vaccinez vous est-ce que je repose la
question jean louis m'a répondu un peu
mais pas beaucoup
est ce qu'il ya une mesure est ce que la
mesure de fermeture des frontières ne
rencontrerait pas plus de consensus dans
l'opinion que l'obligation vaccinale
je pense qu'il a eu à connaître un
retard initial colossal et pour des
raisons idéologiques
c'est que lorsque lorsque le le virus
est apparu
bon on a refusé de faire des frontières
37 une idées d'extrême droite c'est le
virus ne connaît pas les frontières et
ce sera bon plus tard lorsque lorsque
l'on a atteint des proportions
colossales
oui on a fermé les frontières ce qui
prouve bien qu un que c'était possible 2
que c'était nécessaire et là je pense
qu'on a de manière coupable pour une
fois c'est dans ce sens là qu'ils les
donnent aux jcc révéler néfaste tout le
monde on accuse d'autres d'être
idéologues là ce refus supposé d'une de
logique à mon avis a conduit à faire des
erreurs
aujourd'hui face aux variants delta ben
oui bloquons ça continue le quai
frontières en tout cas vivement
mais le variant d'état il est sur le
territoire donc maintenant il faut
éviter qu'ils circulent en plus à long
terme empêcher les gens à long terme
d'aller en italie en espagne au portugal
en angleterre c'est quand même pas une
solution c'est une solution d'urgence
façade pour 15 jours pour un mois pour
un mois et demi là pour les vacances
sont finies pour sélectionner pendant
leur mandat avec le jeu wii avec les
relations plus d'un mois jean comment on
a confiné à chaque fois plus d'un mois
oui mais justement mais il faut quand on
peut l'éviter évitons le sac personne
n'a considéré que le confinement c'était
là la voie royale de la libération des
gens la question c'est est ce que
justement pour éviter parfois le
confinement est ce que farm et des
frontières
un peu plus longtemps n'est pas plus
viable que de que de condamner
les populations à être confiné à un
répit non mais vaccinez vous ça vous
convient dernière question que vont
faire emmanuel macron le gouvernement
sur cette question là là on sent que
tout se met en place pour préparer les
annonces d'une obligation qui va aller
jusqu'où mais voilà je j'ai cru
comprendre mais c'est pas des formations
que je donne vécu j'ai cru entendre ça
que jean castex allait s'exprimer jeudi
en fin de journée pour précisément
annoncée en tout cas la stratégie de
long terme en matière d'obligations dont
je sais rien mais j'espère qu'il ne sera
pas timide parce que l'idée de dire il
faut simplement que ce soit les
soignants etc
ça veut dire qu'on a une réticence sur
le principe que en réalité on comprend
le réticences nous il faut il faut y
aller moi je crois qu'il faut donner la
durée aux gens emmanuel lafont avait dit
jamais je n'ai pas on analyse on fait
d'ailleurs on va le revoir pendant que
je donne la parole aux internautes la
vaccine obligatoire de vaccination
obligatoire étant anticonstitutionnel
nous dit cet internaute
en tous les cas elle est pour un certain
nombre de vaccins je vais bien sûr que
est donc là c'est par décret et c'est
tout réponse donc de bus législateur je
ne suis pas pour la vaccination
obligatoire nous dit louis hawks il mais
je suis pour que tout le monde se
vaccine l'obligation nous dit claudius
de vaccination pour le personnel en
contact avec le public ne me semble pas
être une atteinte majeure à la liberté
individuelle la liberté individuelle
doit s'effacer devant l'intérêt
collectif olympique j'ai choisi de me
faire vacciner je me porte très bien et
nicole je suis vacciné mais contre
l'obligation surtout pour les jeunes et
des enfants est plus favorable qu'un
autre problème il ya il peut y avoir en
dessous de 14 ans
on n'a pas très bien mesurer encore et
les effets donc il faut être il faut
être
c'est pour ça qu'il faut il faut quand
même mettre aux normes et s'imposer seul
point de vue qui compte c'est pas c'est
pas un point de vue d'opposition de
principe
chacun est libre de faire ce qu'il veut
mais qu'ils ne viennent pas se plaindre
après nous dit chantal on va regarder la
réponse à la question twitter êtes vous
favorable à la vaccination obligatoire
et vous êtes une petite toute petite
majorité très courte répondre non à 51%
merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu pour
alimenter poursuivre le débat comment
toujours invité au figaro je suis
toujours invité par vous même toit
explique vraiment sympathique à lui
toujours en minorité vous faites par
combien minorités visibles et on s'en
réjouit pour alimenter poursuivre le
débat ces deux tribune publiée dans le
figaro
oui à l'obligation vaccinale pour
retrouver notre liberté notre prospérité
signée olivier babeau on espère que
sacha va avoir le temps de la mettre
dans le chat et la tribune d'emmanuel
hirsch insistons sur le devoir
démocratique de vaccination plutôt que
sur la contrainte non on n'y revient pas
on a débattu sur ça c'est poursuivre le
débat et les grandes figures de la
droite livre co dirigée par guillaume
tabard est également jean christophe
buisson avec une contribution de jean
louis bourlanges c'est bien sûr à lire
voilà un livre à lire cet été merci de
nous avoir suivi et on se retrouve
demain avec guillaume roquette a très
vite sur figaro live 18h la prise de
parole de christian jacob a très vite